si tratta di settore di oggi lo volesse
di ricordate l'ha fatta tantissime volte
tempo fa indovina serre hanno disdegnato
non lo puoi fatto con visa referente
dipendiamo
pensavo ci fosse il giovamento emesso
roma della guardia da comunque vediamo
se l'italia indovinerà più di me ma se
ci vediamo se voi riuscite indovinarne
più di noi quindi mi raccomando segnate
nei punti ad avere un porto io io
dovrete scrivere nei commenti quanti
punti avete fatto vediamo se abbiamo
fatto più punti noi io abitare a voi
siete propri programmi tutto si sarà
dura
qual è il reale e qual è disegnato
questo alla nostra
a sinistra e di roma cosa di strano
quindi diciamo numero 1 e numero 2
scrivete nei commenti da un numero uno
qual è il reale numero uno o il numero
due numero 2 reato secondo me sì anche
secondo me questo è quello reale e
questo e quello disegnato qui il numero
due reali scrivete voi i commenti quale
reale secondo voi vediamo 21 erratico
cartonato comunque fatto bellissimo
fantastico super realistico wow è troppo
bravo a orly andate a vedere il suo
canale perché super bravo allora il
round numero 2 un'isola trovare lo re o
falso
tra tutti questi è l'ingegnere se vi
ricordate le altre sale se le avete
viste e fatto di vernice tipo non l'ho
disegnato di rifici del secondo voi
quale scrivete destra e centro sinistra
io dico mi butto dico che io stavo
pensando a quello rosaliani sembra più
strano riff talian oppure pure questo
quindi tu dici questo e io dico questo
vuoi fare di te vediamo
[Musica]
non mi va bene tutto
se tu credi che voi fate deviare
schiaccia l'occhio vigile una dai questo
è facilissimo non è molto facile numero
3 qual è quello reale decisamente io
dico questo
voi quale dite che quello reale primo
secondo per un sacco di tempo tra
l'altro metterli tutti i precisi atti ok
niente
siamo 2 a 3 questa è la fase della
[Musica]
boeing
magari ha fatto solo una foto e poi la
stampa da no perché lui disegna tutto
oppure tutta la pernice
che bello ma il bravissimo anche se
stessi si vedeva un progetto è come un
disegno bellissimo difficoltà media
una di queste foto di vernice attenzione
mai più difficile io dico questo non lo
so mi butto dico questo tool vale il sì
mi sa che hai proprio ragione quello
dice quindi anche tu copiare no e perché
avevo visto lo sai che anche coloro è
leggermente diverso dai quali vinte
scrivete nei commenti
perché poi verde blu giallo o arancione
vediamo seguente che anche il colore
alle giornate diverso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
spesso non tutte bene si è fatto ma 329
con 233 nona l'orgoglio dentro a 467
[Musica]
[Applauso]
euro è troppo veloce però non riesco a
vedere ma non c'è tutto il tempo per
capirlo comunque no non me ne ero
accorta partire fatto benissimo a voi
non eravate accorti
ecco come l'hanno segnata anche tutte le
concorsi è bravissimo
[Musica]
allora difficilissimo versione genio
quindi è la più difficile qual è quella
finta ottimo è possibile con gli egizi
che wow
allora mi sta attirando questa gialla
qui questa qui è così se però non sempre
bene le altre possibili potrebbe essere
non so anche questa o questa o questa
vabbè buttiamoci tu dici questa mi butto
e dico anche questa guarda guarda e fate
presto questa una forma un po strane
allora io dico forza 12 telefono
suggerito io
vediamo sicuramente non è una di queste
noi vediamo
[Musica]
nonno legionella
ma non c'è solo rossa linate non
accorgersene più di diverta mamma
dovevamo pensarci per più tempo come
cavo lo ha fatto a disegnarlo così bene
incredibile ma quale qual è quello reale
quello reale forse quella sinistra
questo questo sì sì anche secondo me qua
sembra reale anche questo però è vero
che un disegnino sicuro quindi dico
questo si è comunque è perfetto questo
quindi vediamo voi
secondo voi qual è quello reale
scrivetemi con me si vola paura che
siano il contrario lo sai guarda guarda
appunto di colori mary qui e qui sono
più chiari se mi sa che questo è quello
che vediamo
[Musica]
o al bellissimo ma
ora voglio vedere come ha fatto il
disegno perché la perfetta
[Musica]
incredibile quanto tempo messo a fare
questo disegno bravissimo e prossimo
quale reale quali disegnato wow sono
tutti i reali cioè ti sembrano tutti i
reali non c'è scritto quanti sono reali
quanti sono disegnate penso che solo uno
si ha disegnato penso è incredibile sono
perfetti infatti luce non è così
rivedere che disegnato per sequenza sono
qualcosa che non mi convince servo
peuple meno lucido io stavo avvertire
questo in realtà però adesso non me
l'hai fatto notare si sarà da capire
secondo voi qual è quello disegnato in
questo caso qual è quello disegnato io
dico questo anche io e gli altri secondo
me sono tutti veri perché sono perfetti
voi quale di tenerezza
ok a singapore dove abbiamo fatto
indovina le prime due minuti tutte
tranne quelle super difficili delle
caramelle guarda ma è bravissimo questo
tutto con i portelli prossima tappa del
dr
ha anche l'effetto lucido con il bianco
[Musica]
davvero bellissimo il tasso minimo della
natura è fatto tipo tridimensionalità
del gioco anche con le luci per fare a
fondo l'ombra
allora prossimo difficilissimo anche
questo come ha fatto a disegnarlo
attaccarlo li aspetta risorse per fare
cosa
[Musica]
come non è possibile sono tutti per i no
forse questo qui sembra appoggiato vede
infatti si vede che il mio colore
leggermente diverso in più la luce i
riflessi di luce sono rotondi mentre qui
sono tutti i tondi cioè scusa sono tipo
è perché circolare diversa allora non so
come sia possibile che se non ho
disegnato io dico che ho scritto di
sicurezza vediamo coi quali di macomer a
tutti ricordo
perché ho visto che la strada di forzare
con la fianco si era con la fianco
wow come posso indovinare brava l'ho
girata un po a caso voi siete riusciti
deporre comodo e offertagli prossimo
abbiamo contanti arance e mandarini
quale r allora io penso di aver visto
quello disegnato penso sia maria già
notato ma forse più di uno ma dovrebbe
essere solo uno
io dico che come questo e questo fa ciò
che erano aggiunto cambiare idea e non
mi voglio copiare basta secondo me
questo dice voi che ne dite
scrivete nei commenti vediamo è tenuto
cotto un vecchio non è quella questo
vitale non può compiere mi risposero noi
bambine vestite riusciti a indovinare
generale e questo disegnando finalmente
questa sembra più sfocato non ha molte
ombre quindi direi questo reale e questo
disegnato secondo voi quale fa moeller
tale e quale disegnata scrivetemi con
quello che stai generale crediamo questo
progetto che sarà pur mangiando
caspita sembrava più vera quella finta
dove magari più bello finto tutte
vestite secondo te qual è questo è
disegnato e questo colore che dice che
queste disegnate questo è reale si no
secondo me questo è disegnato e questo è
reale scrivete voi nei commenti quale
disegnato il quale reale di che la carte
molto strane come te ci proverà quello
lì
[Musica]
ho visto io si pensi ancora che quello
sta e disegnata per ha fatto meno bene
ma siete riusciti a dominarlo che sto
disegnato e questo è reale questo è
disegnato sempre essere reale
sì anche secondo me questo e disegnate
queste reale questo è ancora più
complicato di segnare prima di dettagli
scrive secondo voi qual è il reale quali
segnaliamo avete indovinato private nei
commenti nel reale quali disegnato dio
questo veramente veramente difficile
questo è disegnato a questo il reale
io dico il contrario che questo è il
reale questo è disegnato voi cosa dite
scrivete nei commenti vediamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
questo mangiano tutti nazione è allora
quello che si mangia basta comunque a
perfetto e difficilissima singolo bring
spinta
oddio mi sembrano tutte vere secondo voi
qual è quella finta i giudici questa io
non lo so non lo so ora per mi butto
dico questo
forse questa potremo effettivamente a un
ombra un po diverso proprio come fatto a
indovinarlo voi che bravo a dominarla
il mio curare bene i dettagli però era
super cadere al e poi insegnato a salire
chigi
allora io dico che quello di sopra è
reale e questo è disegnato ti c'ero io
riesco a vedere nessuna differenza erano
per lei io sono un esperto di cioccolato
e cosa vuoi fare reale con le disegnato
quell'ottobre è reale o quello sotto il
reale non lo so mi butto è detto che
questo reale quindi io dico che questo è
reale questo disegnato vediamo chi vince
è uno dei migliori direttori ma secondo
te io posso mangiare nel cartone è un
mangia cioccolata
una rosa quale reale quale disegnata
come un pagine gli a queste cose così
realistiche la rotta e complicatissima
allora si capisce un po forse dal ramo e
dalle foglie le foglie c'è questa pietra
in inganno ma queste qua invece sono un
po più si vede che sono un po più
disegnate però nel ramo c'è una
sfumatura un po particolare e anche
ideale i petali sono i dei no io vedo
che ripete ripeti la sfumatura del
bianco qui si vede che ricreata mentre
questa proprio la sfumatura della rosa
secondo la quindi questa disegnata voi
che dite
vediamo ieri però è perfetta che quando
lo sciopero è fatto benissimo è
impossibile da distingue di vedere come
ti quale reale secondo voi questo reale
e questo è disegnato si unica cosa
diversa è un po il colore è successo
così anche sul muso vedi qui ci sono
tutte le sfumature quando si quindi
questo è reale decisamente anche se
dall'uomo
fatto benissimo ma anche reali erano
disegnate pensavo che le ali fossero
vere perché erano wow proprio
tridimensionali anche nei a oreno
disegnate cosa sarei presa per disegnare
così bene fantastico ma indubbiamente
fatto noi ovviamente come sempre abbiamo
perso il conto basta e voi avete seguito
il conto con se stesse ricordo il mezzo
eventualità perché finora sbagliato un
bel po forse meno se volete vedere altri
video fantastici di howard lee lo
trovate appunto lo zucchero si chiama
power lì ed è un genio del disegno
quindi andate a vederlo
hai lasciato un bel live se volete che
rifacciamo una challenge del genere
fateci sapere che altre challenge volete
che facciamo e ora vi lasciamo con
quattro castellinese criticare per
vedere i nostri altri video che il caso
superiore per ritardare la